[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  all right let's get you plugged in  Withey or is it wifey why don't we just  go in and we are online  cool  [Music]  super excited this one minor thing what  is the internet holy cow look at all  this stuff tail stars went to prison  number six will amaze you ladies and  gentlemen the next item up a black  velvet painting of a sorrowful kitten  it's like it's looking into my soul yeah  that one's really gonna haunt me for a  while  [Music]  Thank You Lucy good see I don't  understand why people like this game  raised in mud shake it up pick it Peggy  [Music]  kitty for a little while  no the kitty gets the milkshake the  bunny okay  [Music]  you